everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm today were going to be
covering a game two of the 2014 World
Chess Championships Game one we had a
draw between Magnus Carlsen and vision
on and game two we have Magnus Carlsen
playing the white pieces and vision on
playing the black pieces so we're going
to get started Magnus Carlsen started
with pawn to e4 so pretty excited to see
that more of an aggressive opening then
let's say pawn here to d4 which is
usually what we see at the high-level
play vision on responds with pawn to e5
Knight f3 knight c6 and so we get into
the Rui Lopez after Bishop here to b5 in
a few different ways that Vichy Don
could approach this you could play pawn
here to a6
he could play pawn here to d6 he could
play Knight to f6 a lot of different
options he chose for the Berlin defense
and that is the Knight to f6 sometimes
can be somewhat draw definitely a solid
defense from black what interesting is
Magnus Carlsen actually plays the Berlin
defense with quite frequency and he
knows this defense inside it out so
interesting to see vichy and on playing
against someone who knows this better
than maybe anyone out there so
interesting to see how this will
continue we first see pawn here to d3
solidifying this pawn chain right here
sometimes it's pretty common to just see
castle on the Kings side right here even
if the knight takes here you're going to
see the rook swing over here to e1
usually not going to see that but
instead we do just instead see pawn here
to d3 Bishop to c5 castle on the King
side and then pawn here to the six
getting ready to castle on the Kings
side as well we now see rook to e1 a
very interesting Magnus Carlsen when he
was playing against the Berlin offense
just in the candidates tournaments last
year he played pawn here to c3 so I
guess he and his colleagues or the team
he's kind of prepared this for usually
have an inner circle of really top
players that you prepare for specific
openings may have looked at this and
said okay rook to e1 maybe gives us a
better chance than the pawn to c3 which
magnus carlsen is going to be playing
for a while so castle on the Kings side
from black and then white takes here on
c6 it is also interesting because
usually white waits for pawn here to a6
first so you could try a different thing
you know Mike to c3 and then after pawn
to a6 we now see the exchange knowing
that this is maybe a little bit better
pawn structure for whites going into the
in game but instead just decides to go
ahead and take with his Bishop here on
c6 so after they exchange then pawn here
to h3 controlling the square here on g4
so this light square bishop can't come
out to g4 and this Knight can't come
here to g4 as well blacks now going to
centralize his rook here on e8 and then
Knight to d2 and what's interesting is
Knight to d2 is not a move that you
typically see in this variation this is
a pretty common variation Knight to c3
is a lot more common and so you have
players like magnus carlsen that are
getting so deep into these openings
they're finding these small improvements
or nuances to different openings that
haven't really been seen at high level
play and so this is again maybe a player
that's going to transform a lot of the
metagame
almost for some of these openings Knight
to d2 very interesting move right here
allows him to come to b3 if he wants to
to attack this Bishop also to come to c4
maybe more of a centralized outpost here
that he can now attack a5 so a lot of
different options with this Knight but
it does also mean that this Bishop Aaron
c1 is going to be hanging out for a
little while not going to be getting
involved too much into the game now this
Knight comes back here to d7 also
something that you don't really see from
black if you kind of look at it it makes
more sense to get this Bishop involved
so Bishop to e6
it seems very logical to me as I look at
it centralizing your Bishop developing
more of your pieces this is really
controlling the center of the board rook
over here to b8 controlling this
semi-open file is always good for your
rooks this pawn right here on a7 is
under no pressure at all so this seems
like a pretty good move so Knight to d7
again to Knight moves here that
they're trying to set up for more of a
central location for their nights but
moves that you typically just don't see
so we now see night two a c4 getting
ready to maybe go Knight to a5 and then
attack this pawn here on a c6 vichy nas
decides to go ahead and bring his bishop
back here to b6 controlling the square
here on a5 opening up the opportunity of
magnus carlsen wants to go ahead and
exchange right here
you know vision on no longer has his
double pawns here on the C file so this
is one option on board Magnus Carlsen
doesn't wanna do that right away and
said plays pawn here to e4 starting to
add more pressure on the Queen side just
responded with a pawn here to a5 from
vision on and then we now see the
exchange oh maybe Magnus Carlsen likes
the setup a little bit better than the
pawn back here on a 7 but either way
Magnus Carlsen now decides to go and
push forward with pawn here to thee for
trying to break up the center control
that black has with this pawn here on e5
so Queen here to see seven and then rook
to a3 again one of those moves that you
really have to be an aggressive player
to play you know just as I kind of look
at the board it's not very common to
play rook here to a3 looking to swing
this room over here especially against a
grandmaster maybe lower level play you
want to get just all your major pieces
on one side of the board and attack your
opponent because you know you're going
to make a mistake but usually you know
Queen to d3 continuing with you the Bell
mate getting major pieces involved into
the game maybe not a great square for
this dark square bishop although it does
want to get this involved into the game
g5 just kind of hanging out there can't
really come to f4 right now but maybe
after the exchange of the pawns he can
Bishop to d2 doesn't seem too bad maybe
then he brings his queen to e2 and try
have some sort of play on the light
squares or maybe control this efile if
he wants to but rook to a3 was not
something that I was expecting but
definitely excited for him to play it so
that he can really start a strong attack
on the King side we now see the denied
come back here to f8 so the Knights kind
of moving all over the place maybe this
is opening up the door to play Knight to
e6
maybe Knight - G
later on into the game but usually just
moving or night all over the board seems
a little bit passive it's just kind of
responding to it max magnus carlsen is
doing right now
after the pawn takes are right here then
we're going to see the knight come over
here to h4 opening up the door for this
light this Queen here on the light
squares to go ahead and get involved on
the kingside roof over here to d8
controlling this open file now the
Queen's going to come here to h5 so a
pretty aggressive move we now see pawn
here to f6 controlling this pawn that
White's attacking with this Queen right
here Knight to f5 nice little outpost
move for whites and then we see bishop
here to e6 centralizing developing piece
for bishi and on now a few people looked
at this and said this bishop here to e6
probably not the best knock more
actually tweeted earlier today that he
thought Knight to e6 is really where
this night belongs especially in kind of
the exchange variation of the right
Lopez again these players think about
the game in a whole different way
Bishop to e6 seems reasonable I think
it's completely okay to play this you
definitely want to get your light square
Bishop involved into the game even
Knight to g6 seems fine to me that's not
kind of a move that has kind of been
talked about it's played later in this
game but I think even in this position
right here Knight to g6 is completely
fine it kind of stops a lot of the
threats that White has maybe later vichy
UNAM wants to get his light square
bishop involved but it decides to go
ahead and start with Bishop here to e6
and then the rooks gonna swing over here
to g3 s we talked about that's kind of
why he want to bring it up here
get as much forces as you can starting
to attack his opponent on the King side
now Knight to g6 and now pawn here to h4
so my name is cross and again throwing
everything at his opponent if you kind
of look at it vision on is just kind of
trying to play defense
he's completely not doing anything as
far as proactive Magnus Carlsen has all
the attacking pieces right now so it's
just a matter of you know conditioning
on hold on maybe try to found some
counter play later into the game maybe
on the on the Queen side maybe he can
control this
file right here long enough to maybe get
some counterplay but right now he's
definitely just playing defense now the
bishop takes we do see in exchange now
the pawn is going to come to f5 forcing
the knight to move
now the Knights going to be attacking
this Queen so we're just going to see in
exchange right here again that dark
square wasn't doing too much so the fact
that he can just go ahead and exchange
with that piece right there on F word
that's going to be completely fine now
this works can swing over here a to c3
and start to just attack more material
on board so he's attacking this pawn
here on c6 this Queen is defending that
now we're going to see the pawn push up
here to c5 so it does have a little bit
more protection from this pawn here on
b6 then this works in swinging up to e6
now it's attacking both this pawn here
on b6 also this pawn here on f6 we see
the rooks coming over here to be again
all these pieces that we as we look at
it are really just offensive magnus
carlsen just a little bit better
position now all of a sudden his rook is
attacking not only this pawn here on c5
but also the pawn here on f4 black all
of a sudden all he sees his Queen his
most powerful piece that's defending
this pawn also defending this pawn right
here so any any misstep and all of a
sudden his entire structure is going to
be lost we do see the Queen come here to
a d7 getting ready to try to have some
last-ditch effort to kind of come down
here and attack his opponent Magnus
Carlsen does have a definied with his
Queen here on h5 so we just see that the
King to h2 doesn't want to have to worry
about things too much
rook over here to f8 now the troops on
screen over here to e4 trying to double
up on this efile right here rook to b7
wants to make sure that black controls
this seventh rank right here it's always
important especially if you have rooks
and queens on board that you don't let
your opponent control the seventh rank
if they do bad things happen now the
Queen's going to come back here to e2
tripling up here on the e-file pawn here
to b5 not doing too much trying to
counter play on the Queen side a little
bit but there's not going to be too much
going on this pawns protected by the
rook here on e4 so it's not real clear
how
the chignon is going to continue but for
the most part he needs to make sure that
he's defended against these rooks and
Queen here on the e-file anon responds
with rook here - before attacking this
pond this works on swinging up here to
e7 attacking the Queen the Queen has to
move he can't take this pond right here
although it may look like it after the
rook takes right here
White's up and material black can't
actually recapture if he does try to
recapture then the Queen can just come
here to c4 and there's no real way to
stop White's attack you know if you try
something like King here to h8 Queen
here to f7 can't really stop the attack
here this rooks going to fall if we try
something like that it's going to be
checkmate so not many great options
right now so vision on doesn't even want
to try to deal with that pawn because it
is somewhat of a trap right there
although magnus carlsen more than
anything is just trying to put pressure
on his opponent he knows that his
opponent is not going to take that pawn
right there so queen - a d6 Queen here
to f3 not only kind of stopping this
pawn pushing forward with a discovered
attack but also adding a defender here
and then also opening up kind of a
backdoor to controlling this b7 square
which could potentially if vision aa
makes a mistake open up the door for
from Magnus Carlsen to control that
seventh ring so now we do see an
exchange the Queen's going to come here
to e4 and then pawn to f3 a discovered
check so that the pawns kind of forced
to move here to g3 no other real option
and then in the game we see pawn here to
h5 and this is kind of the mistake in
the game Magnus Carlsen now plays Queen
here - b7 Magnus Carlsen now controls
this important seventh rank there's no
way to really stop this right here
envision odds actually forced to resign
in this spot now you could have come
back if we can't look at and say instead
of pawn to h5
you know obviously that's going to be
bad he could try Queen to d2 and then we
see Queen taking here on f3 Queen taking
here on
see - so if we count out material you
know why it has five pawns Black has
five pawns there's no clear way right
now for white to go ahead and win this
but in the game unfortunately he did not
do that we see pawn here to h5 Queen
come up here to b7 white completely
controls this and there's no way for
really to stop this if the King comes to
h8 again you know the rook takes here on
g7 it's going to be made very quickly
you know black could if you wanted to
just go ahead and sacrifice his Queen he
could play you know Queen takes here on
e7 and then the Queen captures here on
e7 yes it's not going to be checkmate
right away but you know - Carlson has a
huge lead of material this Queen can
just pretty much gobble up all these
pawns on board so in this position
vision on looked at it recognized he had
made a huge blunder given up that very
very powerful seventh rank right here
and was forced to resign so Magnus
Carlsen after two games is up an entire
point so it's going to be very very
difficult provision on he does have ten
more games left in this series so it all
is not lost but Magnus Carlsen usually
only gets better over time he just kind
of has that ability is kind of weird
down to his opponent so definitely not
good for vision on hit they both have a
rest day tomorrow and then they'll be
back the following day so vision on will
have the white pieces hopefully you can
get back on track make this thing
producing but a very very solid game for
Magnus Carlsen put a lot of pressure on
his opponent especially in the middle
game didn't give vision on any
opportunity for counter play and then
just over time more and more pressure
and eventually vision on cracked made a
mistake in Magnus Carlsen want so hope
you guys enjoyed this video commentary
on the World Chess Championships excited
to see all these games played and I'll
see you guys in the next one thanks for
watching